pour vous pourquoi y at il une haine
anti-flic puisqu'on voit que seulement
43 % des français font confiance aux
forces de l'ordre
quand vous expliquer ça à côté moi je
pense qu'une majorité silencieuse qui
aime sa police simplement elle ne le dit
pas vous savez il ya une déclaration
dégradation du climat social
on le voit depuis des mois voire des
années et engendre aussi une
radicalisation de la violence anti
policiers on le constate depuis les
manifestations très durs qu'on a vu le
premier 8 décembre 2018 le 26 mars 2019
ou on l'est de reconnaissance dans la
haine et sur des personnes qui
n'hésitent pas à aller à l'affrontement
direct avec la police donc on est obligé
d'user de coercition pour faire cesser
des infractions et les délits et là on
est dans une spirale très inquiétante
c'est vrai vous êtes inquiet on est très
inquiet très inquiet surtout par rapport
à l'épuisement des forces de l'ordre ça
j'en parlerai plus tard ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire là dessus
monsieur castanet à skis c'est un bon
ministre de l'intérieur je n'ai pas
d'avis ces questionnaires à la base
c'est un homme politique à vous savez il
a récemment fait quelques déclarations
déjà faites attention il faut respecter
la déontologie
ces déclarations là on les a pas
entendus le premier lui décembre lorsque
le dernier rempart de la république la
presse nationale a maintenu la
république en france en face parce qu'il
y avait tout de même des émeutes et
c'était vraiment un maintien de l'ordre
très dur et très difficile avec des
centaines de collègues ont été blessés
alors vous avez chacun une question pour
vous pouvez lui poser des questions
aussi sur twitter puisque nous sommes en
direct et dans un sens vous aurez des
invités surprises qui veut démarrer
bernard bernard phase i oui d'un mois
d'abord je défends la police parce que
je crois que si jamais on n'aura peur
alors il ya des brebis galeuses on l'a
dit et redit si effectivement et pour
une minorité on dit la police son
comportement à l'externe on sait pour
une minorité pas faire de généralités
comme souvent c'est souvent le cas dans
moi je la défends la police tout
simplement parce que si demain il n'y a
pas de policiers pas deviendra mauricie
a pas de maintien de l'ordre
c'est l'anarchie houba houba ou c'est
pas possible
ma question est simple est-ce que quand
on vous a touché suicide quand on voit
toutes ces images et 56 suicide dans la
police est est-ce qui a toujours autant
d'envié vous pensez chez des jeunes
d'intégrer les policiers écoutez le
problème c'est qu'il ya une des petites
des motivations au sein des troupes
au jour d'aujourd'hui non mais je ne
parle même pas de ceux qui sont qui sont
démotivés et malheureusement trop se
suicide mais ce que est ce que vous
sentez qui a des jeunes qui ont envie
vous d'être policier parce qu il faudra
quand même y en a dans la creuse - qui
en a encore parce que imaginons le
scénario il y en ait plus ça serait
catastrophique
il ya des collègues il ya des personnes
qui ont un idéal de défendre la
république d'assister de protéger les
citoyens
heureusement qu'un encore et les écoles
de police et tourne il ya des cols des
personnes qui rentrent dans nos rangs
aujourd'hui encore alors en 2010 neuf
races change
vingt mille trois cent six policiers ont
été blessés en exergue dans l'exercice
de leurs fonctions dit me once in a eu
récemment le drame de cette chauve yake
mort d'une fracture du larynx qui a
entraîné une astuce et un contexte de
plaquages ventrale oui il n'est pas le
seul à être mort dans des conditions
qu'on peut dire un peu particulière la
question elle est toute simple
faut-il interdire le placage ventrale
lors d'interpellations
et sinon combien de dérapage ou de
bavures ou tu sais pas comment on peut
appeler ça bâton attendre avant cette
interdiction alors sur le placage
ventrale c'est une technique qui est
enseigné dans les écoles de police dont
sur la pérennité pays ni les gestes
techniques professionnels d'intervention
le claquage entre hal et les bornes et
on utilise un plaquage contre al
lorsqu'une personne ne veut pas
soumettre à une interpellation par
exemple il ya la commission d'un délit
pour menotter quelqu'un qui veut passer
sa communauté
debout peut pas le faire sur le dos ne
peut pas le faire il faut le pacage
ventrale et au delà du placage ventrale
où personne n'en parle bizarrement c'est
qu'effectivement pour ramener le pacage
ventrale ya souvent une techniques
d'étranglement pour amener au sol donc
le plein qu'à vendre à l'on veut dit oui
mais aux états unis il est interdit
bien sûr parce qu'on est à dire au taz
on prend le taser voilà ils font pas de
détails honte à genoux ou très peu le
taser c'est le pacage contre al il ya
des centaines de plaquages ventron tous
les jours sur les interpellations et ça
se passe bien là sur le monsieur chevaux
via mais ces drames on peut pas
cautionner ne serait ce qu'un seul mort
ça m'avait cautionne pas mal interpellé
à ce sujet tout via déjà à mort c'est à
déplorer
quels qu'ils soient mais du coup ça moi
ce que je regrette c'est que monsieur
schubert ne se soient pas soumis au
contrôle lorsqu'il se conclut ainsi
demandé que s'il s'était laissé faire il
serait encore en vie et bien bizarre
c'est que sa faute s'il est mort
carpathia putsch il est bon mais s'était
laissé faire il sera encore oui la rue
son pv et il serait parti voilà je suis
désolé on a eu les témoignages ok pas
dire ça
une enquête l'homme dans ce contexte
très marquée est acuellement comme l'a
dit on aime la police on a besoin de la
police et d'une police vertueuse les
gens quand ils allument leur télé qu'ils
voient les images terribles de cet homme
à terre sur avec trois policiers sur lui
à nancy veut pas dire que bon bah ils
auraient dû se laisser faire vous savez
monsieur les images elles forgent
l'opinion et quand on montre des images
ou des vidéos il faut tout montrer
pointe c'est qu'on monte trois secondes
de vidéo et montre pas ce qui s'est
passé avant qu'est ce qui c'était la
dérive qu'elle était pas arrivé là
qu'est-ce qui la composaient avaient vu
les images où il avait un pistolet de
glace et les policiers que vous avez des
informations voile qui s'est passé par
rapport à ça c'est quand tu ce contrôle
pour une infraction bénigne ça je le
reconnais mais se souvient ne s'est pas
à une procédure d' outrage puisqu'il ya
insulter de tous les noms des collègues
les collègues sont restés stoïques au
bout d'un moment ils ont dit monsieur ly
un ouvrage on va vous interpeller
il ya eu ensuite une rébellion et
ensuite pour l'amener au sol
effectivement il ya une enquête en cours
sur sur cette mort là que je déplore tu
as des plaintes d'anciens loin après on
verra ce que donnera l'enquêté c'est
leur manière ce via selon madame
cheville à votre collègue l'une des
collègues qui a participé à
l'interpellation lui a dit qu'elle avait
vu de ses yeux vu tomber tout seul
écoutez c'est ce qu'elle dit ce que dit
mais c'est pas mal géré une autre
version
mais c'est pas le cas du tout maintenant
les restaurants non mais je veux pas
terminer à la main il ya une enquête
mais apparemment les l'explication de
notamment l'arrivée au commissariat et
tout ça n'a pas été confirmée d'accord
on verra c'est extrêmement triste pour
cette famille
n'est ce pas à toi tu une version il ya
une autre si qui existent non à une
enquête si op laurence et raquel en plus
haut de respect pour la famille voilà
exactement respect pour la famille on
attend l'enquêté c'est vrai que c'est un
drame qu'on a vécu en plus ici sur ce
plateau avec le témoignage de la femme
de cédric souvient et de sa fille et
c'est vrai que voilà on a on attend l
enquête et on n'a pas envie de rajouter
de l'huile sur le feu et de l'huile sur
leur tristesse voilà de rajouter de la
tristesse à leur tristesse puisque
peut-être qu'ils nous regardent ce soit
et qui doivent être extrêmement triste
encore bien entendu donc la société
d'entendre les d'entendre qu'il fallait
laisser faire il ne serait pas mort je
pense que ce n'est pas acceptable
mais la couche dans la novlangue
monsieur ce n'est pas audible vous
rendez pas compte de ce qu'on rajoute en
plus ma deuxième question
une question qui vient de tomber bonsoir
cyrine j'espère qu'il y aura moins deux
ans à une question sur les mutilations
et la justification de ces mutilations
justement de la part de certains
syndicats de police et jérôme rodriguez
qui m'envoient cette question notre
gilet jaune fidh avait perdu un oeil à
un nom maintenance et 26 exactement
alors voilà la question est ce qu'il y
aura moins
est ce qu'il y aura des durera toujours
des mutilations la justification des
mutilations justement de la part de
certains syndicats de police il parle de
son cas regardez il ya un an go justifie
rien du tout d'accord sur les
mutilations haut par rapport à la
personne qui avait ramassé une grenade
qui avait perdu sa main une li évident
il a ramassés çà et là de cette grenade
il fallait pas le faire parce que c'est
très dangereux mais nous on n'est pas
dans la justification
là dessus il ya des enquêtes en cours la
justice passera et on verra ce qui
arrivera tout simplement
raquel garrido vous avez vu dans le
cadre de la mobilisation des retraites
que par secteur les professionnels
enlever leur attribuent leur uniforme
pour les poser à terre donc on a vu les
avocats mes confrères avocats déposer
leurs robes
les ouvriers du mobilier national post
et leurs outils les inspecteurs du
travail leur code civil et ainsi de
suite et ainsi de suite
est ce que vous pensez pas que ça peut
aussi arriver dans la police qu'à un
moment donné
face à cette situation vous deviez vous
même que vous êtes en train de gérer une
situation un contexte politique en fait
est que vous êtes un rempart politique
sous l'ordre de l'état ce que vous
pensez pas que ça pourrait vous arriver
aussi dans votre profession
que simplement rejoignant des autres
professions bas vous déposiez vos
matraque twill osier vos casques et est
ce que est ce que ça ça pourrait pas
changer la situation non pas les
uniformes
on a le respect de l'uniforme 1
représente nous les fonctionnaires
dépositaires de l'autorité publique ne
fera pas il est arrivé sont des
mouvements de contestation ont notamment
pj à quelques années que les collègues
et déposer des armes symboliquement à la
préfecture mais semble laitiers mais
jallet uniforme jeunes et des femmes que
nous portons nous le respectons vous dit
pas on va dire au reste hop on en a
marre on a on arrête mais les collègues
visant omar effectivement il ya beaucoup
de collègues aujourd'hui et notamment
qui font les matières lorsqu'ils sont en
arrêt maladie qui sont en berne
il ya un épuisement des policiers
notamment des serres et c'est surtout
des colères des combats d'intervention
que je voudrais mettre à l'honneur
aujourd'hui vous savez quand vous
travaillez en cycle 4 2 vous avez quatre
jours de travail deux jours de repos
vous avez un week-end sur six quand tous
les week-ends et rappeler n'est plus les
familles vous avez vu de familles
déstructurées et là ça commence à faire
mal
et le problème c'est que là dessus les
donneurs d'ordre notamment à la
direction de l'ordre public et de la
circulation doivent prendre conscience
de cela
vous savez en dessous des éléphants vous
avez des êtres humains quand vous
commencez à 6h du matin vous faites
double vacation vu d'ici à une heure le
lendemain et que ensuite vous
recommencer à travailler le lendemain
matin c'est maintenant le moment c'est
pas tenable ce pacte nabeul alors c'est
le moment de commandes justement bah oui
mais pour être entendu de déposer les
plus gros lot à l'appel à la révolution
encore là mais comme d'habitude là
heureusement la révolution ne m'a pas
attendu pour être là des policiers
arrêtent de nous protéger joliette avait
évoqué l'art été arrêté nous allons pour
l'autre chaos
je suis désolé voilà je vous dis non ba
si bob c'est emmanuel macron qui je vous
dis aucun cas chaque semaine dans ce que
vous montrez vous êtes au local des
chroniqueuses à balances ton post est
donc pour faire du maccabi la révolution
avocate des chroniqueuses à valence au
poste c'est pas qu'il va vous prendre et
eric naulleau
oui on entend beaucoup dire que les
policiers laissent volontairement agir
les casseurs ou même un filtre les
casseurs et se joignent à eux pour
discréditer les manifestants et à cirer
même place que vous la semaine dernière
nicolas dupont aignan tenait d'ailleurs
à ce propos
vraiment enfin il a tenu des propos très
étrange est ce que vous pouvez dire oui
ou non une bonne foi pour annoncer c'est
ce que cette pratique existe mais on ne
peut pas imaginer ce à une seconde c'est
strictement faux monsieur du poignant
c'est un homme politique c'est pas
possible tout simplement pas moi j'ai
jamais vu ça en 26 ans de carrière c'est
pas aujourd'hui que ça va commencer
impossible ça c'est des conneries
impossible c'est une légende urbaine les
deux sfr est infiltré bien sûr je peux
vous le garantir
on va pas décemment laisser des
personnes commettre des exactions sans
pouvoir réagir
notre boulot nous c'est de réprimer les
infractions écrit l'édile comment vous
expliquez que c'est plus efficace envers
les manifestants qu'envers les casseurs
dont très peu sur les habitudes se font
avoir
vous savez les casseurs les type bac box
qui sont des professionnels de la
guérilla urbaine qui fonçait dans
l'hérault dans toute l'europe mais
depuis le temps sont très rodée il
s'immisce au sein des cortèges et
souvent vous avez des manifestants il ya
un phénomène d'entraînement attention la
plupart des personnes que nous mettons
en garde à vue qui agresse ou lancent
des pavés sur les forces de l'ordre pour
la plupart beaucoup d'entre eux
maintenant donc pas de casier c'est une
première infraction
d'accord et ça nous déplorons on a peur
un peu de ce phénomène d'entraînement
qui est un peu inquiétant
karim rocco je pense que les français en
un sentiment ambivalent dans le rapport
à la police dans leur immense majorité
je pense qu'ils font preuve de
compassion sur la difficulté qui relève
de l'exercice de votre fonction je pense
aussi son opposition que vous n'avez pas
les effectifs ni les moyens matériels
d'exercer votre métier dans les
meilleures conditions
on sait qu'il y avait une 6 millions
d'heures supplémentaires impayées que
parfois sur les manifestations avaient
été obligés d'aller acheter sur vos
deniers personnels
le matériel de maintien de l'ordre le
car vous n'êtes pas suffisamment doté un
effectif que vous êtes sur tous les
fronts vous avez trois week-ends sur 4 2
où vous êtes dehors du matin au soir je
pense que les français ont conscience de
sa rocco en même temps il ya un doute
qui s'est installé dans
la tête de nos concitoyens sur le
sentiment d'impunité chez ceux au sein
de la police nationale
une minorité sans aucun problème qui
bafoue les codes de déontologie qui ont
fait état de dérives qui n'ont pas
respecté les règles fondamentales dans
l'exercice d'une fonction qui est noble
on a des gens qui ont été les borniers
des mains qui ont été arrachées parfois
des gens qui ont été agressés alors
qu'ils ne représentaient aucun danger
pour les forces de l'ordre je pense
qu'il ya des images qui ont semé le
doute dans les esprits parce que ces
images là n'était pas suivie de sanction
évidente pour les fonctions de police
qui avait bafoué sais quoi d'autre
george est une question très clair on a
une instance qui s'appelle l'inspection
générale de la police nationale igpn qui
est en charge sur le plan administratif
pas judiciaire que ce soit clair ce
qu'ils aiment parquet soit pas
judiciaire de traiter les cas de
bafouement et de dérives de non respect
au code de déontologie simplement sur
l'année 2009 rocco 313 cas ont été
remontés l'igpn
à ce stade on est au mois de janvier
fin janvier 2020 il n'y a pas de
sanctions qui sont tombés on nous
explique inquiète sont en cours 313
enquêtes en cours
et quand on regarde les années
antérieures
il ya des faits évidents qui stipule le
cadet des enquêtes qui ont été oubliés
des cas qu'on était un peu enterrés
alors après il ya des chiffres aussi de
2500 plein environ qui remonte à l'igpn
ya 16 ans sanctions qui tombent pas
c'est pas rien mais quand on voit le le
degré de violence qui a eu parfois on se
dit avec des images évidente pourquoi
les enquêtes administratives sont si
longues quand pour autant quand on
manifeste on dérape en temps réel on est
capable de lui faire une comparution est
ce que vous ne pensez pas que dans
l'esprit de nos concitoyens une igpn
indépendante qui ne serait pas sous
l'égide du ministère de l'intérieur qui
ne serait pas composé uniquement de
fonctions de police car c'est le cas
aujourd'hui l'igpn est sous l'égide du
ministère intérieur est composé de
commissaires d'officiers de police vont
rejoindre les mauriciens qui ont servi
pendant droit sion de cul entre elles se
protègent et ce sentiment là sème le
doute
un doute qui est malsain 2 qui fait pas
de grands airs police républicaine
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas imaginer ni
gipn indépendante ou n'intégrerait des
avocats on intégrerez désespère de la
sécurité qui ne seraient pas des
fonctions de police et où on stature et
plus vite sur les quatre de derrière un
candidat commun syndical east alors deux
points déjà sur l'igpn
il faut savoir comment ils fonctionnent
j'ai peine l'adderall alain rôle d'audit
sur l'organisation des services et un
rôle de contrôle sur la déontologie
elle est saisie et être saisi la hulpe
est saisie d'ailleurs depuis 2013 par
n'importe quel citoyen en ligne ensuite
elle a ainsi instruit les affaires soit
il ya un classement sans suite soit
c'est une sanction dite administrative
et quand c'était un délit quand c'est
judiciaires et saisi le parquet donc
j'ai pas un travail sous le contrôle du
parquet je vous livre un élément
statistique important sur toutes les
sanctions disciplinaires sur toutes les
procédures d'ici père de la fonction
publique d'état sur la police nationale
ne représentent que 7% en volume de
poursuites disciplinaires d'accord et
soit 100% façon de 100% de collègues
sanctionné dans la police nationale donc
vous savez quand un collègue pas ce que
j'appelle moi j si les trois fois la
veille la nuit dont il est intraitable
accès policiers ou quand alors structure
un arpent nantes justement j bien sûr
pourquoi pas gérer simplement qu' il
faut bien le board et parce que le
risque c'est de voir si vous faites faut
faire très attention il faut des
professionnels des personnes qui
connaissent bien la police nationale
leurs conditions de travail des experts
parce que le problème c'est que si vous
mettez entre guillemets n'importe idée
là dedans vous pourrez avoir des
personnes qui ont des a priori déjà soit
cuite nationale hélas ce ne sera pas
équitable
normal à l'apnée sûr donc vous ne seriez
pas contre en tennis c'est une grande
avancée je vais vous dire dans la paix
de la recherche d'une paix joue concorde
a beaucoup de confiance retrouvée
sous réserve notre sous réserve s'il
joue réserve que ce soit bien bordé
chacun environ
monsieur castaner nous entend de ce soir
il ya une part de cette période